sur les maisons ou les immeubles.
On a étudié les résultats.
On pensait trouver moins de pesticides là où les abeilles se portent mieux.
Ce n'était pas le cas.
On a trouvé dans notre étude, les barres orange c'est Boston,
on a pensé que ces barres seraient plus basses,
avec le niveau de pesticides le plus bas.
En fait, on a plus de pesticides dans les villes.
Donc l’hypothèse du pesticide qui sauve les abeilles...
moins de pesticides en ville
n'est pas correcte.
Et c'est typique dans ma vie de scientifique.
A chaque fois que je fais une hypothèse,
c'est son contraire qui se vérifie.
(Rires)
C'est une trouvaille intéressante hein ?
Passons à autre chose.
L’hypothèse des maladies
On a examiné les maladies de toutes nos ruches.
On a trouvé dans une étude similaire en Caroline du Nord :
aucune différence entre les maladies
en zone urbaine, suburbaine, rurale.
Partout les abeilles sont malades et mourantes,
il y a plus de maladies des abeilles dans les villes.
Comme ici à Raleigh, en Caroline du Nord.
Une fois de plus, le contraire de mon hypothèse de départ se vérifie.
Continuons.
(Rires)
L’hypothèse de l’habitat.
Les zones où les abeilles sont prospères auraient un meilleur habitat --
plus de fleurs, ok ?
On ne savait pas comment tester ça.
J’ai donc eu une réunion très intéressante.
Une idée a germé avec mon amie et collègue Anne Madden,
intervenante TED.
On a pensé à la génomique, comme AncestryDNA ou 23andMe.
Avez-vous fait ces tests ?
Vous crachez dans un tube et dites « Je suis allemand ! »
(Rires)
On a développé ça pour le miel.
Avec un échantillon de miel on regarde tout l’ADN de la plante,
et on dit « je suis sumac ! »
(Rires)
Et c’est ce qu’on a trouvé ici à Provincetown.
Donc pour la toute première fois, je vous rapporte
quel type de miel vient d’ici de notre propre communauté.
HoneyDNA, un test de génomique.
Le miel de printemps à Provincetown vient du troène.
C'est quoi le troène ? Des haies.
Quel est le message ?
Ne coupez pas vos haies pour sauver les abeilles.
(Rires)
Je sais que ça fait baba cool et c’est controversé,
avant de nous lancer des tomates,
allons vers du miel d’été, qui est du miel de nénuphar.
Si vous avez du miel de Provincetown, ici en été,
vous mangerez du jus de nénuphar,
et à l'automne, du miel de sumac.
On apprend sur la nourriture comme jamais auparavant.
Et on peut désormais donner pour n'importe quel aménagement urbain
les bonnes plantes à cultiver,
et ce que les abeilles feront pour le bien de votre jardin.
Pour la 1ere fois pour chaque communauté on a la réponse.
Le plus intéressant pour nous est en approfondissant les données.
Si vous venez des Caraïbes et voulez explorer votre patrimoine,
Le miel bahaméen provient de la famille du laurier,
avec des saveurs cannelle et avocat.
C'est incroyable de trouver 85 espèces de plantes
dans une seule cuillère de miel.
C’est la mesure que nous voulons, les mégadonnées.
Le miel indien : c'est du chêne.
Chaque échantillon de ce type vient du chêne,
172 variétés de saveurs dans dans un bout de miel indien.
Le miel de Provincetown part de 116 plantes au printemps
jusqu'à 200 plantes en été.
C'est le nombre pour tester l'hypothèse de l'habitat.
Dans une autre approche,
sur la nourriture nous obtenons des bonnes données.
Nous découvrons que dans les régions rurales
un échantillon de miel contient en moyenne 150 plantes.
C'est une mesure à la campagne.
Les banlieusards, vous en pensez quoi ?
Plus ou moins de plantes dans les banlieues avec pelouses,
jolies pour nous mais terrible pour les pollinisateurs?
Les banlieues ont une très faible diversité végétale,
donc si vous avez une belle pelouse,
tant mieux pour vous, mais vous pouvez faire plus.
En plantant des fleurs sauvages sur une partie de votre pelouse
pour diversifier l'habitat,
pour améliorer la santé des pollinisateurs.
Tout le monde peut faire ça.
Les zones urbaines ont le meilleur biotope
vous voyez ici : plus de 200 plantes différentes.
Pour la 1ere fois, l'hypothèse sur l'habitat se vérifie.
Nous savons aussi comment travailler avec les villes.
La ville de Boston a un biotope huit fois meilleur
que ses banlieues proches.
On peut l'étendre à l'échelle gouvernementale.
Vous penserez ma pierre tombale dira :
« Ici git Noé, plantez une fleur. » N'est ce pas ?
Je veux dire...c’est épuisant après tout ça.
Quand on regarde l'ensemble,
les gouvernements, les urbanistes...
à Boston, le miel vient des arbres de tilleul,
on leur dit : « si un arbre meurt remplacez-le, pensez au tilleul. »
On peut faire des grandes choses en travaillant avec les autorités.
Là c'est le toit de l'entreprise Fred.
On peut planter ces trucs sur les toits du monde entier
pour restaurer l’habitat et sécuriser l'alimentation.
On a travaillé avec la Banque Mondiale et la délégation présidentielle de Haiti.
On a travaillé avec des diplômés de Yale et d'Ethiopie.
Dans ces pays, nous ajoutons de la valeur au miel
en l'identifiant,
en les aidant sur quoi planter
pour restaurer leur biotope et sécuriser l'alimentation.
Mais quand on pense aux catastrophes naturelles.
Pour la première fois,
nous pouvons obtenir une mesure complète de tout biotope
avant qu'il soit détruit.
Pensez à votre ville natale.
Quels sont les risques causés par l’environnement ?
Comment nous allons sauver Porto Rico après l’ouragan Maria
Nous avons maintenant une mesure de base du miel,
l'ADN du miel avant et après la tempête.
Nous avons commencé à Humacao.
C’est là que l’ouragan Maria a frappé.
Nous savons quelles plantes remplacer, la quantité et où,
en triangulant des échantillons d’ADN de miel.
On peut même penser que ici,
la belle terre qui nous connecte, qui nous a façonnés,
toute la science citoyenne,
l’érosion, les tempêtes d’hiver
qui deviennent plus violentes chaque année.
Qu’allons-nous faire à ce sujet
pour notre terre précieuse ?
En regardant l’ADN du miel,
on voit les plantes bonnes pour les pollinisateurs à racine profonde
qui sécurisent la terre,
et ensemble, tout le monde peut participer
et la solution tient dans une cuillère à café.
Si votre ville natale est balayée par une catastrophe naturelle,
nous avons maintenant un plan prêt à l'emploi
pour tout réparer sur Terre,
ou peut-être même dans une serre sur Mars.
Je sais que ça semble fou, mais pensez à ceci :
un nouveau Provincetown,
une nouvelle ville natale,
un endroit familier qui serait aussi bon pour les pollinisateurs
pour une alimentation stable
dans le futur.
Maintenant, ensemble, nous savons ce qui sauve les abeilles...
en plantant des biotopes variés.
Ensemble, nous savons comment les abeilles vont nous sauver --
en étant des baromètres de la santé environnementale,
en étant des plans, des sources d’information,
petites usines de données suspendues dans le temps.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)